[Music]
Katy Perry has been putting her life out
there for the whole world to see her
stunts inside that big brother-type
house is generated more than 49 million
views and she posted this thank you
today quote couldn't have done it
without all the fantastic people that
came over to help start conversations
and now the kitty has left her house she
is definitely not going back into her
shell the video of the year goes to Katy
Perry Katy Perry she's won dozens of
awards but here's what she really thinks
about them telling the New York Times
quote all the award shows are fake and
all the awards that I've won are fake so
thank you so much to everybody who
helped she always seemed grateful when
picking up trophies but now says to her
the shows don't represent the fans
kitty tells the times she is now
revealing her true self born Catherine
Hudson she believes the old Katy Perry
is gone she changed her look chopping up
her hair and as we saw from those
emotional four days in her witness house
she struggles with how the world looks
at her I so badly want to be Catherine
us and that I don't even want to look
like Katy Perry anymore sometimes and
she's opening up more about her love
life saying a desireable mate is quote a
man of quality and equality Katy
complements ex-boyfriends Orlando Bloom
John Mayer and ex-husband Russell Brand
saying they quote are beautiful in their
own right what the 200 to get nasty lady
is an open book these days and now so is
her witness House fans are able to visit
it and are posting their own stories
from inside
[Music]
you